زمن الجواسيس عاد واليوم شبيه بالبارحه
نحن نعيش اليوم فتره زمنيه مماثله لما
كانت عليه الامور خلال الحرب البارده بين
الاتحاد السوفيتي والولايات المتحده
اقتباس من كتاب البحث عن جاسوس الكي جي بي
في المناصب العليا في المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه لروبرت باير وهو ضابط سابق
بوكاله المخابرات المركزيه تتكرر بين حين
لاخر عمليات القبض على جواسيس بين البلدين
لكن هناك قصص كبيره ففي عام 2019 قلل
الكريملين من شان قصه كبيره تقارير
اعلاميه امريكيه عن جاسوس لسي اي اي كان
يعمل في الرئاسه الروسيه وصفتها موسكو
وقتها بانها محض خيال رغم الاعتراف بان
الشخص المشار اليه عمل في الكريم موسكو
كانت ترد على تنفيذ المخابرات الامريكيه
لعمليه عام 2017 لتهريب اكبر مصدر سري
للمعلومات من داخل روسيا ظل يمد واشنطن
بمعلومات سريه على مدى عقود الان ونحن في
عام 2023 تغير الامر لم يقلل الكريم من
قصه اخرى وان بدت اقل خطرا ايفان جيرش
كوفيتش او قرش كوفيتشا مراسل صحيفه
الامريكيه اعتقلت موسكو اليوم بتهمه
التجسس لصالح واشنطن الكريم المشهود
هذا من اختصاص جهاز الامن الفيدرالي لقد
اصدروا بيانا وليس لدينا ما نضيفه هنا
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكنني قوله هو انه تم
القبض عليه بالجرم المشهور